salut les filles et bienvenue sur mon
blogue vidéo
le lnd riou viou tu m'inspires club
chaque semaine je vais vous donner des
petits conseils et des petites astuces
pour savoir comment ces coins du glamour
comme moi alors aujourd'hui sur maps
toujours sommaire du jour est bien des
petites astuces simples et faciles à
réaliser à la maison c'est le fooding
mas cup alors le fooding mascotte
c'est simple s'est accommodé vous reste
c'est pas la peine d'acheter un mas cup
tout près en pharmacie avec un peu
d'ingéniosité et trois francs six sous
on peut très bien le dire en euros ça
fera plus moderne
ah ouais avec un peu d'âge inusités et
3,06 ou on peut sans honte de leur
intercession tadis où ça fait plus
anciens qui devrait dire six ans tu as
compris non 10,3 euros c'est sous 3,06
ou mais voilà tu as compris ah oui voilà
c'est pas grave on n'est pas un brin de
s'emmerder aussi près les lettres alors
maintenant plus tôt alors pour le
fooding mas cup et bien au lieu de jeter
ce que vous avez périmés dans le frigo
on va s'en servir de base pour faire le
mas cup
eh oui c'est comme ça aussi sur mon blog
on arrête le gâchis mesdames parce que
ça suffit cette société où si kong âge
tout le temps qu'on jette tout ce qu'on
a dit que c'est périmé et qu'on s'en
sert pas alors qu'on pourrait non voilà
donc qu'est-ce qu'on a qui s'accommode
avec presque tout un frigidaire etc et
bien souvent périmés trop vite je vous
le demande en mille il ya du monde merci
bébé je voulais faire la surprise là
c'est parce que j'ai vu qu' on a vu dans
le frigo
ben oui parce que j'avais acheté exprès
pour le tuto alors ce que je veux dire
peut-être
monde mais j'ai envie de taper dedans ah
non alors là tu es gonflé pierrick ah
non c'est pas possible ça moi je me
protège à tous les amis d'hier matin
moi j'aimerais pouvoir continuer sans
que les cours soient définitives à
plusieurs pour boucher les voies terre
bon ou c'est que j'en étais oui alors
donc le fooding mas cap c'est terminé
j'espère que ça vous a bien plu
alors surtout s'il veut bien les étapes
que je vous ai dit il suivait pas les
conseils de laurie 75 sur son vidéoblog
1 qui racontent n'importe quoi cette
[ __ ] chronos kaunas klaus cola soit
khronos group menaces